and so today I wanted to explore some of
the async patterns that are emerging in
nodejs that are that are going to
basically cause all of us to write
software in very very different ways one
year from now than we do today
specifically for this talk I have three
goals my first goal is to describe the
landscape write JavaScript changes very
quickly note is moving at a really fast
pace and even when you live in it every
day like I do it can still be hard to
keep track of you know which proposals
have been accepted which have been
rejected which have been silently
ignored you know what's safe for
production what's unsafe for production
what needs a feature flag and what does
and it can be really hard to keep all
this in your head and so the first thing
I'm going to do is kind of explore the
current landscape as it is right now
both on the browser and in node for
JavaScript the second goal of the talk
is to explore some of the obstacles that
are unique to our node.js community
there are a couple barriers that might
get in the way of us taking full
advantage of some of the really cool
JavaScript technology that's going to be
available in the next few months and so
I'd like to address those and see if
there might be ways for our community to
work around them and my third goal for
this presentation is to propose some
best practices for you guys for 2017 and
what I really mean by that is to beg you
to adopt my opinion so that I can stop
debugging callbacks all day right so so
everything here is just just a little
bit subjective but but please keep an
open mind so let's start with the async
landscape I know everybody here is you
know a smart experienced JavaScript
developer but I'm still gonna start with
the foundations right let's let's start
talking about async primitives in
JavaScript and what does that mean right
the the lowliest most humble async
primitive is the callback and all the
other ones are based on the callback
right could you raise your hand if you
can think of at least two other
primitives that
we use for async operations and in node
okay there's a couple people yeah well
there's actually there's five more
things that that we use to deliver work
asynchronously in node but they all
depend on the callback
the first is timers right when you need
to respond to physical time
asynchronously the next is event
emitters and this is when they're events
that may happen multiple times or may
never happen and you need to be able to
respond to that we have streams which is
how you respond to asynchronous data
reading and writing asynchronous data
and then we have promises and promises
are basically a way to encapsulate
information that may or may not exist
yet and finally we have a sink oh wait
could you raise your hand if you've used
a sink oh wait yet okay only a few
people that's pretty much what I've been
expecting a sink oh wait is personally
my favorite feature of JavaScript
full-stop right I would give up
basically everything else just to get a
sink oh wait it's amazing and I think
it's gonna revolutionize the way we all
write code every day and what's really
fascinating about this is that the the
deadline for async await being in
browsers and being a node is coming up
very very rapidly like this is this is a
technology I've waited for for years and
it's about to happen at the end of the
year right now with these primitives you
can do pretty much anything you want in
JavaScript this is this is why I know it
is a great concurrency language but you
can't use these primitives everywhere
all right only callbacks timers and
promises can actually be used across the
board whether you're working in a
browser or a node event emitters and
streams are pretty much node only at
least by default and then async await is
kind of weird because you actually get
support for async await in every major
browser right now but only the latest
nightly builds and you have vanilla
support for async await right now in the
latest version of node note 7 but only
behind a harmony flag right so so it's
right on the cusp of being a viable
technology that you could just use every
day and
production application either on the
client or on a server right so so this
is a really really good time to be
looking into it if you've never tried it
before so most of the examples I've seen
about promises in async/await
online have been sort of abstract and I
wanted to make something that was a
little bit more realistic
in fact I'm gonna you know rewrite a
small piece of a service that we use at
Heroku to serve node runtimes
right like let's imagine that you are a
cloud hosting company that's somewhat
obsessed with the color purple and you
need to mirror node runtimes from
node.js org locally in your data center
because you want to be able to build
people's nodes app note node apps really
quickly and you don't want to have to
fetch it from node.js org every single
time right so whenever a new version
node comes out you need to make a copy
of that and you're gonna write a service
for this well the first thing you might
try is the naive node.js way which is
just concurrency just download
everything at once but there's about a
hundred versions of node and you'll find
as I did that node.js very quickly just
rate limits you and cuts off your access
so instead what you have to do is
asynchronously download pull down all
the versions and then download them one
by one by one until you have all 98 or
so and depending on which of these
primitives you decide to use to do that
your application can be really beautiful
and elegant or it can be sort of ugly
and clunky and so we're gonna look at
three different primitives that you
might choose starting with everybody's
favorite the callback right and just to
prove it this application does in fact
work right so like this is this is the
one with callbacks and it just pulls
down every version of node and downloads
it locally piece by piece and if you
just let it run you'll eventually have
every version of node on your laptop so
anyway so we'll start with callbacks
what is the the first thing you notice
about this code for me it's that it's
about 30 lines long to basically pull a
list of stuff and then loop through that
list and download it
that's that's a little bit embarrassing
right like my rubyist or Python friends
would would make fun of me because their
languages could do this and maybe a
third the space and it would be much
easier to read right like there's
there's a lot of boilerplate here
because I can't use native language
constructs to do the loop I have to do
this whole next thing and have callbacks
another thing that you you start to
notice is that somebody who's never seen
this program before might be a little
confused first opening it up because
it's not immediately clear what it does
or how it works or what order things go
in and in order to understand that you
actually have to read through it line by
line and closure by closure and if you
do you start to notice other code smells
one of them is that there are two
identical error handlers at very
different parts of the app they do the
exact same thing but they're they're
duplicated and and so this is pretty
much idiomatic JavaScript today like
this is how you would write this in a
callback style and it works fine there's
nothing wrong with it but but it's it's
maybe not the most elegant way to solve
the problem so let's look at the promise
based solution now caveat I actually
don't like promises right like I'm the
guy that's a holdover for callbacks I
use them daily I until recently have not
been adopting promises I don't see a lot
of benefit to it promises increase your
complexity and they only increase the
efficiency of your code by a little bit
they just they solve a couple of the
problems that callbacks introduce but
they also introduce their own problems
and their own complexities and their own
boilerplate so I don't really love them
right and but but this is a small
improvement all right does anybody
notice any any initial improvement here
like in the first ten lines you can see
what the program does and how it works
you don't have to read the whole thing
you can just scan the first ten lines
and have a pretty good idea about what
this program is gonna do and in what
order it's gonna do it so that's already
an improvement the other really big
improvement here is that it has one
place for handling errors which is which
is nice so that's not duplicated across
the code
but has anybody noticed something that's
like kind of weird hard to read wonky
it's that bottom piece that download
piece right it's like what the hell is
this you know it's I'm like reducing
starting with an empty resolved promise
chaining multiple promise thenns on to
it with the download so so what this is
essentially doing is keeping all of my
download promises from running at the
same time so it'll run the first one and
then it you know Maps the dot VIN method
of that promise onto the subsequent
promise and then once that resolves it
Maps the next dot then and you make this
promise chain then then then then for
every node version right that's what
it's doing but it's unfortunate that I
have to explain that because that's a
pretty simple thing what is it doing
it's a for loop right but it doesn't
read like a for loop and it doesn't look
like a for loop and it would even take
an experienced developer awhile to
figure out what the hell that code is
for so this is a little bit shorter than
the callbacks I would say it's at least
as hard to read as the callback solution
and I and I don't love it but again this
one does also work right so we have the
promises version here and its behavior
is identical so so then what does this
look like with async await well it's
only a little shorter but that's already
better but more importantly it's
infinitely more readable it has one
logical block the subsequent lines run
after the previous lines right like line
10 is gonna run after line 8 you know
line line 12 is gonna run after line 10
like as you go through the lines that
also represents your time series you
don't have to mentally keep track of
your stack and your closures to figure
out when things are gonna run and which
things are gonna run before which other
things and whether you have any race
conditions etc so that's one really nice
thing about this the other really nice
thing about this is all of the error
handling is done in one place but it's
even better than the promised version
because all of your synchronous
and asynchronous error handling will be
done by this try cache block right so if
you if you Jason dot parse something and
that throws an error that will be caught
or if you typo node.js org and you throw
a asynchronous error when you try to
pull some domain that doesn't exist that
will also be caught in this try cache
block so so it starts to bring together
the way you address synchronous and
asynchronous code it's also really easy
to read I'd say somebody can open this
up scan it and understand basically what
it's doing right away and then the final
thing that's really nice about this code
is that it's just using a regular dam
for loop to loop through all of the
versions of node there's nothing special
required here like there is with
callbacks and with promises you just
loop through them all and then oh wait
now I'm sure that you know I saw earlier
many of you have used async away so I
don't want to harp on it too much but
what this is essentially doing is
whenever you see this a weight keyword
it's saying stop execution of this
function here don't go on to the next
line go resolve the promise that's after
the awake keyword and then once that's
resolved keep executing the function
right so this program is going to run
it's going to do the options thing and
then it's going to get down to that let
index line and it's gonna say oh wait
we're awaiting this JSON request so
we're not we're not going to go to line
10 until we get that JSON request back
so it's just gonna sit there and nodes
event loop is going to keep running and
other functions are going to keep
executing it's not going to block but
this particular function is gonna stop
executing until that promise resolves
and then once it does it's like okay
great so now we have index we're gonna
pull versions out of it then we're going
to loop through all the versions we're
gonna figure out what the URL is for the
version and then line 14 lit download
equals a wait request that's where we
download the node version and again it's
gonna say oh we're awaiting a promise
here so it's just going to sit there
this particular function and not move
forward until that download completes
which is I know that sounds trivial if
you're used to a non Java
environment but this is a very special
thing for JavaScript and what's cool
about the way note does this versus how
you would see very similar code in Ruby
or Python is that while node is waiting
here the event loop is taking care of
other work you're serving requests
you're pulling down different files
you know the node hasn't stopped just
this function is frozen which is a
really powerful abstraction so so I hope
you agree that this is much much better
this is the kind of code I want to be
debugging from our customers in 2017 I
don't want to be diving through layers
and layers of callbacks anymore right so
so I wanted to show that to explain this
callbacks are the backbone of everything
you need callbacks for any of the other
abstractions without callbacks you can't
have promises because callbacks are used
to implement promises similarly without
promises you can't have async await
because async await is implemented via
promises right you have to have promises
to have async await so I don't really
care about promises myself I don't
really like them but I think that
they're absolutely critical to the
future of JavaScript because if we don't
start moving towards a promise first
environment then we're never going to
get to this sort of async oh wait mekka
right are there any questions so far
before I move on so the second thing I'd
like to talk about is the obstacles that
the node.js community faces in
particular trying to trying to take
advantage of some of this new technology
that's really fantastic browser-based
developers are going to be getting async
await for free really soon all three
major browsers are about to introduce it
and beyond that the client-side
developers don't really have to do that
much but in node we're facing some sort
of unique challenges so at Heroku I
spend a really good chunk of my life
analyzing other people's JavaScript code
and I dare you to find a more depressing
sentence than that
so you know we we have automated systems
in place that track relative popularity
of dependencies we track which types of
applications have more issues and which
run more smoothly we get a lot of sort
of anecdotal evidence by diving into
actual customer code and helping them
with weird problems usually if we have a
VIP customer that has some really weird
performance issue it eventually gets
escalated up to me and I take a look at
it right so so what's really cool about
that is that I get to experience
hundreds and hundreds of like Enterprise
Production apps every year and just kind
of see how they're written and what
choices different developers and
architects made about them and what's
scary about that is that I see what
decisions were made and what different
developers and architects decided to do
with their production apps and these
insights have led to a few conclusions
at Heroku the first is that many
developers are not comfortable
transpiling servers right so they're not
comfortable using babble-on server-side
code and I'm actually I don't love it
either and what's important about that
is that right now there's not really a
great way to do things like async/await
you either use babel with a stable
version of node or you use node seven
with the harmony flag but node seven is
unstable right so neither of those
solutions are really perfect for running
a production application many developers
still prefer callbacks to promises and
if you want to see open source at work
you should go through all the github
issues for node and promises in core
it's it is it is an incredible rabbit
hole one of the things you'll find is
that many core developers actually
prefer callbacks and that's because
callbacks map really really well to the
underlying C++ system that powers node
right like like the API between v8 and
node is essentially a callback api and
so there's not a whole lot of desire to
change that into a promise based API
who here uses express raise your hand
now raise your hand if you use Cola I
see one person congratulate a good job
so I love Express and I've used Express
for years but I think it's very telling
that a much much older callback based
web framework is still an order of
magnitude more popular than its
spiritual successor which uses
async/await Kohli is beautiful to work
with koa 2 which uses async/await and
promises but very very few production
applications are using it yet and I I'm
saddened by that Bluebird and queue
which our third-party promise libraries
were downloaded 18 million times last
month now the reason this sucks is
because that's pure fragmentation we've
had native promises in node since 0.12
which was released two years ago right
but third-party promise libraries are
still being downloaded millions of times
a month which means that when I look at
production application dependency trees
I frequently see two three four
different promise libraries all being
used interchangeably and this is not
great one of the reasons it's not great
is because async/await forces you to use
native promises there's no way to
override the kind of promise that's used
when you create an ASIC function it's
going to be a native one so we should
all just get on board with native
promises and make them as good as we can
be
modules with promise based api's are
still the exception I want to show this
fantastic video from a few years ago
about that because everybody uses this
like if you publish a module that like
returns promises or something nobody's
gonna care nobody's ever gonna use that
module right so now that's old but it's
still largely true right and what what
we're seeing is sort of a schism in
JavaScript between the groups of
developers who have decided that they're
gonna go all in on promises and
everybody else and everybody else is
still the majority right so so even
though it's not entirely true that no
one would ever use your promise library
it's still it's still the exception
right and what sucks about it being the
exception
what sucks about it being the exception
is that in order to make callbacks and
promises interact with each other you
have to wrap them they're not just you
can't just glue them together so it
makes it harder to just pull in some
modules and write an app note core is
still call back only so all the basic
note API is the file system API the HTTP
API these are all still call back only
good and if you look at the pull request
so people in court really do want to get
promised support in they know that
async/await is coming you know some of
them are freaking out about it a little
bit because they realize that
async/await is gonna be like in node
before it's really ready and so there's
a pull request to get core support for
promises but it's been officially
stalled since June it also has not been
updated since February right so it's
like out of date and there are still
discussions on it like should we even do
this yes yes we should right so um so
these are all reasons that while the
greater JavaScript community might be
getting all sorts of really awesome
async functions node and our ecosystem
especially might be lagging behind right
like this is why we can't have nice
things y'all you know because we just
can't agree on the best way to do things
it's a community problem more than a
technical one so here's my plea to you
people because you guys are leaders in
the JavaScript community right at
November I have met I've met Enterprise
architects I've met people who write and
maintain node modules I've met tinkerers
and hackers many of you lead influential
teams or write influential code so I'm
going to beg you to try a few things and
2017 the first thing I'm going to beg
you to try is to commit to a promise
first API for all new code you write if
I can do it you can do it because I
don't like promises either right but if
you don't do this if you don't try to
write promise based api is in 2017 what
that means is you are putting a really
really tight
by date on whatever modules or
frameworks or applications are writing
because they're not going to be
compatible with the async primitives
that exists by mid 20 2017 in standard
browsers and standard node the second
thing I'm going to ask of you guys is to
use native promises don't install
Bluebird don't install queue don't write
your own promise library just use new
promise it works great
right this will reduce fragmentation in
our community and also make it so that
when people want to improve promises
instead of doing it in some in like
their personal favorite user land
promise library they'll be more
motivated to improve promises for
everyone and the third thing I'd like to
ask you to do is to sell your team on
node 7 right as you can see here with
node 7 you can run async functions
without any translation you don't need
Babel you don't need anything special
you can literally just install node 7
and run node - harmony and suddenly
async async and await work in your code
it's fantastic right so so sell your
team on that because I think it's really
important that people start to see the
benefits of async await or they'll never
really commit to the pain that is
promises right so it's important to like
dangle that carrot out there for people
one of the challenges behind this is
that node 7 is still unstable but that's
ok because in April of 2017 Note 8 is
going to be rolled out it will have
async/await support it'll just be
basically you know node 7 will be just
rolled into node 8 and so as long as
whatever production application you're
releasing isn't released until April
you're fine and you'll be able to deploy
with a long term support version and
finally any time you see any code that
looks like this I just want you to take
a step back and think do I really need a
third control a third party flow control
library and this is there an alternative
way I could do this maybe with async
await maybe just with promises you know
like how could I restructure this
asynchronous code and finally if you
only take one thing a
away from this talk it's that JavaScript
in 2017 is only going to be as awesome
as we allow it to be but if as a
community we move in the right direction
over the next few months that is going
to be pretty damn awesome so thank you
[Applause]